well it's this has been this has been an
abysmal abysmal uh administration and
it's only it's not it's not even been a
full year so we're already getting this
check this out we're already getting
rumors that joe biden is not going to be
running in 2024. so who do you think it
might be could it be hillary clinton no
daily mail reports clinton's belief that
the presidency is her birthright and
deep unpopularity of biden and harris
could see the former first lady run in
2024 politics insider warns
and i do not disagree i don't know if i
believe she would because she is deeply
unpopular herself but she came out
recently and she was like here's the
speech i would have given if i won could
you just give me a second to rant about
that by the way
when on god's green earth has anyone
lost as much as hillary clinton and been
given so much time to talk about all the
things that she wanted to do or would
have done had she won like democrats in
general fail up like pete would judge
anybody but i am just fascinated by the
fact that we keep giving this one like
what was she on the today show or
something like it was a legitimate
mainstream media show with millions of
viewers where like she's given a prime
time a block slot to talk about here's
the speech i would have given
okay here's the speech i would have
given had i been born giselle bunchen
had i been yeah exactly had i gotten an
oscar here's the speech i would have
given isn't she doing a master class or
something yeah yeah selling it
right now my favorite my favorite joke i
saw was someone said what's the master
class going to be pointing out wisconsin
on a map
that's the one she would need standing
by your man
having great relationships
winning elections well um
now let's be real those are things she
was all really bad at but she could but
the media pretends that she is good at
all right right it's like they give her
the opportunity to give that dumb speech
but i gotta give her because they feel
like she should have given that speech
and they also are signed on to it being
her okay okay yes yes yes but as much as
many people don't like hillary clinton
and i'm not a fan i think we absolutely
need to recognize what she is really
really good at the things she's done
really well like
running the clinton foundation while she
was running the state department and
taking donations from foreign
governments to large sums and then all
of a sudden when she was no longer a
contender for the presidency or in the
white house those donations started to
dry out i got another one i got another
one i gotta know i just got one really
quick one
making sure that her husband goes on the
epstein's island he's very good at that
the the maxwell trial i follow all the
conspiracy theorists on the gram about
that but uh yeah she's also really good
at just
signing on hollywood money and hollywood
celebrities and
going and partying and stuff she's great
being connected to harvey weinstein as
well i mean that's a great yeah yeah
well that's how you all demonstrate she
knows how to pick them did you see that
you saw the video of her crying right
it was the weirdest not cry like fake
crying i'm i'm sorry they came out and
you know everyone ragged on kyle
rittenhouse saying crocodile tears yeah
i'm like the dude's having a panic
attack yeah anything but like that was
ptsd that kid needs to be i will say
this he's getting therapy because okay
thank you because i the mom and me is
like stop doing interviews start doing
therapy right he is he that was the
trial because you are young
and
in 10 years
it's gonna hit you you need to you need
to
take a beat i feel like someone should
have told that to hillary when she was
much younger yeah because something is
wrong with her something something from
a very young age so did your mom ever
tell you like you hey tim you can be
whatever you want to be like there's
moms like you they are unconditional
they're amazing they encourage you so
did my mom she's probably watching right
now hey mom and and like alicia you can
be anything you want to be but it's like
did hillary's mom do that to the nth
degree yeah too much like just too much
like was it weirdly indoctrinated like
did she have goggles on that it was like
fed to her like in zoolander like this
is what you will this is what you will
do and that's why she legitimately
thinks it's her birthday
the reason i don't think so is because
her mom uh has a goat's head and
you know
and claws and
you know created her out of a pentagram
and summoned her from the depths and
probably just you know intent was it was
in inherent within the demonic presence
yeah i was going to say something
similar mk ultra i think that's also a
possibility
but uh who knows but it's over time
exactly but no she's just she's just
she's just an insane person you know
she's she's a sociopath narcissistic yes
yeah ego narcissism i think i think
actually left right or center i think in
order to be honestly
um i think most people in in our
industry so politicians and anybody on a
microphone is typically narcissistic
she's on record celebrating death and
murder and torture she's like yeah that
was great remember when she said she
wanted to drone julian assange
can't we just drone this guy and then
she was like it was a joke i swear yeah
yeah but when mccain said bom bom bom
bom bom i ran
in a q a in 2008 people were like what
ah warmonger neocon so is it yeah is it
okay do you think hillary's gonna run
she's gonna i i don't know i kind of
would be excited for it the hill because
she said she would lose miserably
miserably trump would just win again i
think there's going to be a glitch in
the matrix where we wake up and as soon
as election season starts we're back in
2016 we don't know what happened and
it's hillary versus trump again it's
like what no no it's ian waking up and
he's he was like coming out of a dmt
trip i remember the moment i woke up and
saw trump won and i felt like the wind
was knocked out of me i was like what
was happening what did i drink yeah for
sure it was like totally i was in times
square and you could hear a pin drop and
all the people that went there to
celebrate were all quiet there was like
five trump supporters and you could see
five guys
and everyone's just giving them the
stink eye and i was there filming it
like this is absolutely crazy and
incredible at the same time was it the
crying meme like the crazy crying filled
with people in times square like people
shocked jaws on the floor walking around
aimlessly lost like zombies not knowing
what just hit them and they're watching
all the news like
in total it was it was it was something
to experience it's a night i will never
forget when i watched the new york times
like probability meter it said like
greater than 99 chance hillary clinton
and then it slowly went down i remember
when it hit 50 percent and i was just i
was laughing i was in the sputnik office
and everyone there was like people were
starting to cry because they were all
democrats and then it shifts and then i
remember when it was like trump is
cannot lose at this point cassandra
fairbanks is there she's laughing she
went from crying to laughing to crying
again because she was like sad crying
and then like in the denial i do have to
say so i'm a homebirth hippie and uh i
like
went to this unfortunately cove had
closed down my liberal friends yoga
studio and it was like women only so i
really liked it because i feel like we
were doing yoga yeah dudes and um and
there were a lot of women in like the
full women health yoga class like the
next day that were like i'm just here
for the peace
and i did all of my essential oils and
all of my touch points chunk uger
freaking out during his life it was
hilarious it was crazy i'm just sitting
there like guys okay they're like alicia
what's stressing you today and i'm like
oh you guys
what i find funny too is like my
response to the election with joe biden
was i was like there it is the count is
in joe biden you know is is projected to
be the winner and then they they got mad
at me for that like the the liberals
were like ha ha you're a loser and i'm
like i just
was like yeah he won i don't know you
stated truth truth
trump supporters got mad at me you know
when i said that but i'm just like it is
what it is i don't know what am i
supposed to do about it and they were
like haha you're a loser you voted for
trump and you lost and i was like yeah
i do have to say and i was reading
something the other day as a mom and i
think like it's good for society in
general like we have to learn how to
lose like you have to be a good you have
to be decent at losing to understand the
importance of winning and i think that
if you don't learn that like hillary
didn't
shut up dude just shut up
it is you're not being graceful and
you're not being dignified and you're
not doing the country any good like if
you want to run for president united
states you're allegedly supposed to care
about country first
it's clearly not about country first but
it's going to be okay because a lot of
women are going to learn how to lose at
sports in sports especially
fellow women
yeah yeah well i i it's it's man it's
crazy to me it's been six it's been six
and a half years since i'm like sitting
there watching hillary clinton
announcing she's gonna run and then the
2016 election cycle when she's debating
trump was one of the funniest things
ever
that you know the things because you'd
be in jail it's like
man mike dropped moments people are
cheering they're treating it like wwe
the the debates were definitely more
entertaining i used all the gifs in my
tweets from the debates
like so fun are never fun or funny but
donald trump he brought that
and so so i actually had this
conversation the other day with somebody
uh trump also brought i think like the
cable newsification to politics like
i've often said that the trump family is
like the royals meet the kardashians
because because like that is the kind of
cultural phenomenon that they are and
that he kind of had a thing like they
had hair and makeup people in the white
house for anyone in their administration
that went on camera he kind of got that
the visual and the story it mattered and
that's why hollywood is all about
leftism for a few other things too but
because it's like they are turned to and
have been turned to for decades to
create the narrative and to create the
story to help democrats win and
republicans have often failed at like
the emotion and the story of things well
this is something that andrew clavin
talks a lot about he talks about how
conservatives are so bad at turning the
story in their favor we don't understand
the importance of the arts we don't
understand the importance of movies or
books or anything like that and that's
part of the reason that we're losing the
culture where this is something that the
left has such grasp on i don't know why
we're so bad at it but i think that for
a really long time we have fled because
we thought that we couldn't win there so
then we flee i mean we see it happening
now with kovad right self-fulfilling
prophecy that people just they run away
they go to the ease of things instead of
like
putting down roots and fighting and
being the odd man out yeah
trump
a lot of people think trump's going to
run
right yeah we know we've even talked to
steve bannon's like he's running it's
going to happen and some of his former
administration
and uh i certainly think so he's been
rallying he's been losing weight i guess
but i mean he's going to be up there too
i mean he's going to be he's going to be
as old as joe biden was when joe biden
ran so he'll be like the second oldest
president ever and he didn't have that
line against biden about how biden was
too old and
yeah but is that anymore trump is spry
yeah i've heard that about him yeah one
criticism that i'm seeing a lot of him
especially when he goes on fox news is
that he's actually supporting uh big
pharma more than his supporters um i've
seen a lot of criticism of him
especially with a lot of the the
mandates and and that he criticizes a
little bit but he still promotes overall
well he considered a mandate
i thought earlier in covin he was like
oh yeah well we should we should have
like a incentive and we should make sure
that everybody gets the vaccine there's
also a lot of criticism from his base uh
of people saying that he just didn't
stand up for his supporters for his
people and that uh there's a huge kind
of disconnect between a lot of people
who are not really satisfied with that
administration as well that needs to be
brought up i think that the number one
um well i don't know i look at 2024 and
i'm like let's just run desantis then we
can have a really fun like lottery of
who we gonna choose for vp and then just
like destroy any of the what was it 11
different democrats and all of the
democrats of the mainstream media is
floating all of the names are awful and
they're all losers once again democrats
fail up no no it was like none of these
people have the advice who is who amy
klobuchar okay um okay okay desantis has
a lot of good energy behind him he does
yes and so i'm just saying like i would
love it i would love it if if people
like any other like republican that's
thinking of running anybody like abbott
anybody else under the sun just i love
you guys you're great keep keep
governing well in your states let's just
give it to desantis and then we can have
one of you great people as vp and then
we can destroy any of these idiots on
this list i think desantis is a better
option although he is more of a
traditional republican in a lot of ways
yes so for me you know we'll see it
really is dependent it's gotta it's
gonna be about what's in the forefront
of his administration and i'm still kind
of skeptical trump i didn't vote for the
first time after seeing what he was
doing i was like this guy's a bow in a
china shop and he's saying no to the
establishment desantis however i think
has proven himself especially with the
with covid so if he were to run i got i
got to say too i'm really impressed with
a lot of these ags on the state level
yeah like um a lot of these attorney
generals like in oklahoma for example
they're kind of like oh you can't
mandate our national guard to have the
jab because turns out we're in charge of
the national guard not the dod so there
you go
and and and i really i'm pretty
impressed with a lot of these like ags
on some state levels and maybe they'll
end up in the senate or something one
day that'd be nice thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you